j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public sur cette date ce
discours historique un roi d'Angleterre
dans l'hémicycle ici au Sénat devant des
parlementaires des deux chambres points
d'or d'une visite officielle de 72
heures qui marque le réchauffement des
relations entre la France et le
Royaume-Uni Jérôme pour sa première
visite d'État en France Charles III
c'est clairement inscrit dans les pas de
sa défunte mère Elisabeth II qui était
venu en 2004 célébrée les 100 ans de
l'Entente cordial au Sénat accueilli par
le président de la Chambre haute Gérard
Larcher la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale Yale Braun pivée il a eu droit
à la revue des troupes de la gare de
républicaine en guise de bienvenue il
s'est ensuite dirigé vers le palais où
il a pu et c'est une grande première
pour un monarque prendre place dans
l'hémicycle sa mère avait dû se
contenter de la salle de conférence
devant 300 parlementaires 150 sénateurs
et 150 députés son hôte du jour lui est
réservé un mot d'accueil vous avez tenu
à
réserver en français
que vous prononcerez dans votre visite
d'État
c'est dire l'estime nouée entre la plus
ancienne des nations parlementaires
le Royaume-Uni et le parlementarisme
français Charles III s'est ensuite
avancé à la tribune où il a prononcé un
discours alternant l'anglais et un
français impeccable après des années de
relation franco-britannique plutôt
fraîches marqués par le brexit il s'est
aussi chargé dans un élan diplomatique
propre à sa fonction de mettre en avant
ce qui
unitaire
en France je reste plus que jamais
convaincu du caractère indispensable de
la relation entre nos deux pays
pour conclure il a mis en avant un
engagement personnel de longue date la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
et pour la biodiversité en joignant
français britannique a avancé ensemble
dans ce domaine ensemble notre potentiel
est illimité
c'est pourquoi nous devons sérieux
et entretenir notre en tant que
pour les générations futures afin
qu'elles deviennent je le propose
également une entente pour la durébilité
les parlementaires lui ont répondu à
leur façon par une standing ovation
dont rêvait le président du Sénat et la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
voilà ce qu'ils ont dit juste après la
standing ovation bonsoir Sylvie Berman
bonsoir heureux de vous accueillir vous
êtes ancienne ambassadrice de France au
Royaume-Uni auteur de Goodbye Britannia
le Royaume-Uni au défi du brexit publié
aux éditions Stock et puis votre tout
dernier livre madame l'ambassadeur de
Pékin à Moscou une vie de diplomate
cette fois-ci aux éditions Talandier
Catherine Marchal bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes professeur en
histoire et civilisation britannique à
l'université Cergy Paris Catherine Morin
de saillie bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes sénatrice Union centriste de la
Seine-Maritime et vice-présidente du
groupe France Royaume-Uni on est
également duplex avec Sacha Mitchell qui
est journaliste en charge du Royaume-Uni
chez nos confrères de Courrier
international bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi évidemment Tam traduit et restez à
mes côtés pour ce second débat je
commence peut-être par le faste de cette
visite on parlera beaucoup plus de
politique après évidemment Sylvie Berman
c'est classique pour un séjour royal en
France le le dîner d'État Versailles on
peut même faire beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus je ne sais pas mais je crois
qu'effectivement ça correspondait à la
pompe britannique qui est la
caractéristique de la monarchie donc
d'ailleurs le président l'a dit en
disant il n'y avait pas de meilleure
lieux pour recevoir le roi Charles que
Versailles souvent les dîners d'État se
font à l'Elysées mais là effectivement
pour bon marquer cet événement
exceptionnel c'est la première visite
d'État du Roi et puis ça rappelle la
première visite de la reine également où
il y avait eu une réception à Versailles
ça alors il y a eu un sondage au luxa
c'est pour nos confrères du Figaro qui
disent que qui dit que 51% des Français
des approuvent le dîner de gala à
Versailles bon moi je trouve que à côté
de ça on était il y a beaucoup de
beaucoup de messages de de joie et de
satisfaction de voir le le roi et la
reine à Paris Catherine Marchal le Fast
d'une réception à la française
voilà à la minute près et donc on ne
peut pas non plus voilà déroger au
dérouler normal même si le roi quand on
le voit il arrive une certaine
spontanéité comme avait d'ailleurs
Elisabeth II et le souvenir avoir
rencontré à l'ambassade de
Grande-Bretagne au moment de la de
l'anniversaire de de la reine donc un
moment émouvant je dois dire un moment
solonel en même temps
dans ce discours aussi qui était un
discours au volontariste pour réaffirmer
cette relation multicellulaire qui lit
bien sûr notre pays au Royaume-Uni titre
personnel En tant que normande j'étais
très sensible parce qu'il a fait pas mal
de références à la Normandie en plus
une solennité particulière au fait que
ce soit dans l'hémicycle c'est quand
même rarissime
Elisabeth II en 2004 elle avait parlé
elle dans le la salle des conférences
qui jouxte l'hémicycle c'est quand même
un peu différent
deux diplomaties et bien au-delà de la
réserve habituelle des souverains
britanniques nous link power on le sait
ce discours est très fort d'abord il ne
s'est pas fait sans Laval du
gouvernement avec des messages forts à
notre
intention on remarquera que les trois
premiers déplacements du roi Charles III
se sont fait en Europe en Allemagne en
Roumanie et en France c'est un signe
fort de volonté de réchauffement des
relations qui étaient un peu glaciales
pendant ces dernières années le
référendum c'était il y a 7 ans 5 ans de
relation voilà inexistante compliquée et
c'était un acte fort on va y revenir
réconciliation en tout cas de
rétablissement de relation normale
Saint-Michel pour savoir comment cette
visite est perdue est perçue pardon côté
britannique depuis longtemps
elle est ravie elle est conquise en tout
cas elle est ravie de l'accueil qui a
été qui a été réservé
au roi au bout de deux jours c'est
considéré comme un succès le tableau il
Bossan ce matin parler de grands oui
Royal cet après-midi des stand up qui
est un quotidien du soir gratuit à
Londres titre et carrément le roi de
France et puis il y a quand même une
petite curiosité dans la dans la presse
britannique pour essayer de comprendre
pourquoi il y a cette une telle
fascination pour la famille royale
britannique en France il y avait des
articles dans daily tallegraphe de
spectre qui essaie de mettre le doigt
dessus à la fois peut-être en se disant
que depuis qu'on a raccourci notre
propre roi dans le contexte de la
Révolution française c'est le terme qui
est utilisé par daily little on essaye
de le de le remplacer il y a peut-être
aussi
l'idée selon laquelle le notre président
le président dans le cadre de la 5e
République est est une figure politique
et qui peut être source de division
c'est ce que disait le spectacle dans un
article ce matin aussi et que du coup la
figure de d'un chef d'État qui est
au-dessus de de tout ça au dessus de la
mêlée politique peut avoir un certain
attrait pour les Français mais après ce
serait celui-ci aussi elle est bien
consciente que pour pour une partie des
Français aussi c'est il y a pas
forcément d'intérêt particulier pour
pour la visite mais en tout cas elle est
elle est elle est ravie notamment de la
réception hier soir
je reviendrai vers vous sur les enjeux
politiques dans un instant Sacha
Michelle effectivement c'est une espèce
de famille royale par procuration on dit
souvent ça ici ici en France je vous
propose tiens sur cela on va se
concentrer maintenant sur la relation
franco-britannique et je vous propose
pour démarrer d'écouter tout simplement
Emmanuel Macron c'était lors de ce dîner
à Versailles un mot clé fascination
nos relations certes n'ont pas toujours
été pacifiques
pourtant ce mouvement docilation cette
valse hésitation magnétique ont
contribué à entre la scène au destins
nos fiertés nationales a apprivoiser
cette ascendant mutuelle French Touch
englomanie pour en faire un ferment
d'émulation
prouvant que s'il y a un sentiment qui
est héréditaire entre nos deux pays ce
n'est pas l'inimitié mais bien la
fascination
comment ça en parler cette visite de
Charles III elle s'inscrit donc dans un
contexte de réchauffement des relations
franco-britanniques et oui vous l'avez
dit Catherine Morin de saillie nous
sortons avec nos amis britanniques
d'années de froid polaire quelques
exemples listres première ministre qui a
battu un record de brièveté qui a été
ministre première ministre moins de 50
jours l'année dernière avait quand même
mis trois mois pour répondre à cette
question considérez-vous Emmanuel Macron
comme un ami ou un ennemi elle avait
fini par trancher en faveur d'amis mais
comme le dit l'adage quand on a des amis
comme ça pas besoin d'ennemis avant elle
Boris Johnson en 2021 avait lui rendu
public une lettre sur Twitter où il
avait beau donné dans le deal Emmanuel
il écrivait notamment je propose que
nous mettions en place un accord
bilatéral de réadmission pour permettre
le retour de tous les migrants illégaux
qui traversent la Manche comprendre vous
les Français reprenez vos migrants de
quoi occasionner une crise diplomatique
d'ampleur entre rosbif et Fruges bref
les années qui ont suivi le brexit ont
été synonyme de dérive anti-européennes
et anti-française et aujourd'hui
l'actuel Premier ministre richissenac
tente donc de recoller les morceaux
c'est ce à quoi on assiste avec cette
visite d'État car faut-il bien le
préciser ce n'est pas le roi Charles III
qui a décidé de partir en goat en France
mais bien le thème darning Street qui
prévoit les déplacements du monarque et
l'amitié franco-britannique a été
célébré de toutes les façons aide à
l'entente cordiale par le roi Charles et
par le Président de la République
Emmanuel Macron pris littéraire
franco-britannique qui a été lancé de
concert par Brigitte Macron et la reine
Kamila ont encore diplomatie jusque dans
l'assiette hier à Versailles où le comté
trois ans d'âge à côtoyer le stichelton
fromage anglais donc et où Gérard
Larcher donc pour voisin de table Mick
Jagger on a cru avoir des visions lors
de ce dîner mais cela ne veut pas dire
qu'un miracle va arriver et que les
années d'incompréhension entre Londres
et Paris vont être effacés d'un seul
coup car ce qui compte bien sûr vous le
savez Thomas ce sont les preuves d'amour
donnez-nous des preuves d'amour il y en
a quand même eu quelques unes il y a
deux semaines on a appris le retour des
chercheurs britanniques dans les
programmes européens
auparavant au mois de mars richessenack
a annoncé donner 543 millions d'euros
très exactement pour aider Paris à
bloquer les migrants qui tentent d'aller
autrement cela lors d'un sommet
franco-britannique ou le Premier
ministre Emmanuel Macron sont apparus
très proches ils avaient alors parlé
d'entente renouveler et de nouveaux
départs mais lors de cette visite signe
on retient surtout que Londres et bien
recule sur ses engagements climatiques
c'est tombé hier hasard du calendrier ou
pas richesnaque a parlé de pragmatisme
en reportant l'arrêt des ventes des
voitures thermiques de 2030 à 2035 au
Royaume-Uni finalement il s'aligne sur
l'Union européenne on croirait donc du
Macron et on ne sait pas encore si le
roi Charles III qui est un écologiste
convaincu il y a consacré une large part
de son discours ce matin à apprécié
cette nouvelle alors qu'il était
effectivement en plein service commandé
pour la couronne mais aussi pour le
gouvernement alors ce thème là le le roi
écolo on y reviendra un peu plus tard si
vous voulez bien dans notre débat je
voudrais qu'on reste sur cette question
de d'entente cordiale de relation franco
britannique est-ce que peut-être votre
expérience quand je sais plus à quelle
époque vous étiez vous étiez ambassadeur
à Londres 2014 à 2017 est-ce que vous
avez vécu des périodes de froid comment
un ambassadeur peut travailler vous
pouvez aussi évidemment vous appuyer sur
une d'autres capitales dans lesquelles
vous avez travaillé mais dans une
période de froid polaire comment on
travaille est-ce qu'on réussit à
maintenir du lien c'est quoi le le rôle
essentiel qu'un ambassadeur
l'ambassadeur doit maintenir de toute
façon le dialogue et la relation
bilatérale même quand il y a des
désaccords donc moi j'ai connu deux
périodes une période face avant le
brexit et puis une période un peu plus
difficile et un peu plus acrimonieuse
après le brexit mais il faut dire que
les choses ont empirées en fait avec
Boris Johnson et puis et puis ensuite
avec liste parce que avec Thérèse aimait
les choses étaient plus plus normale
mais c'est vrai que le brexit a créé un
froid que les Britanniques ont considéré
surtout la presse de droite que les
Français avez voulu punir les
Britanniques nous étions toujours mis en
cause il est vrai que depuis le
Moyen-âge c'est quand il y a un problème
au los blame de French
critiquer enfin blâmer toujours les
Français c'est donc
[Musique]
bien sûr une différence parce que c'est
vrai que tous ceux qui étaient
considérés comme partisans du maintien
dans l'Union européenne les remains eux
étaient tout à fait positifs vis-à-vis
de la France parce qu'il regrettait
cette décision mais au cours des années
qui ont suivi les choses ont empiré
alors effectivement il y a cette
citation célèbre d'un éphémère Premier
ministre avec l'histoire mais Boris
Johnson qui parle français qui était un
maire de Londres plutôt amical quand il
est arrivé au pouvoir comme premier
ministre était injurieux effectivement à
l'égard des Français riches cela vous
l'avez dit tant mais comment ça se
passait lui qui propose qui décide des
pays dans lesquels le roi va va se
rendre souvenons-nous que on devait être
les premiers sur la liste puisque
c'était prévu au mois de mars avant
l'Allemagne alors en fait il est le roi
et chef de l'État et non chef du
gouvernement mais le vrai pouvoir se
trouve en fait dans le chef du
gouvernement qui avait ici un acte et
donc ici en fait on imagine bien que les
décisions ont été prises entre eux et
donc bien comme vous l'avez dit il est
venu le roi est venu ici à la demande de
de riches unak donc on voit bien que
comme on l'a dit le fait de venir dans
les trois pays européens dans sa
première année de règne a quand même un
sens très important mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'interroge sur ce qui s'est passé
hier soir ou même moment alors j'étais
vraiment très frappé puisque hier soir
je devais passer sur BBC News Night et
j'ai passé l'après-midi à préparer
l'émission et en fait en milieu
d'après-midi et bien l'émission et on
devait travailler sur la visite du roi
en France et bien en milieu d'après-midi
on voit bien que finalement au niveau
europ éen on a envoyé le roi et on
permet en fait à avoir des nouvelles en
France qui vont montrer cette visite qui
est vraiment un vrai une vraie belle
visite qui est une entreprise de charme
mais de l'autre côté l'autre côté qui
est vraiment très gênant c'est qu'on se
rend compte que du côté du Royaume-Uni
comme d'habitude l'affaire est occultée
et en fait ce qui va vraiment compter ce
sont les élections législatives qui
auront lieu l'année prochaine puisque
c'est ça qui a démarré hier soir
évidemment et c'est ce qu'on a
d'ailleurs reproché à riches un acte de
de prendre ses décisions avec des
animaux électoralistes à ce moment-là on
va écouter un extrait de du discours de
du roi Charles ici au Sénat en fin de
matinée justement sur ce thème de
l'écologie de notre responsabilité
collective
nous devons ensemble
œuvrer afin de protéger le monde de ce
défi
existentiel le plus grand défi de tous à
savoir le réchauffement climatique le
changement climatique et la destruction
catastrophique de la nature
de voir les mesures prises par nos
gouvernements nous citoyens et de plus
en plus par le secteur privé
je pense depuis longtemps que nous
entreprises peuvent jouer un rôle
essentiel on travaille en partenariat et
on amené avec nos gouvernements et nos
populations et investir des milliards
pour développer les solutions qui
permettront une transition réussie vers
un monde durable
j'ai adoré le côté je passe de l'anglais
aux français
c'était très poétique d'une certaine
façon je reviens à la politique cette
fois-ci et je me tourne vers vous Sacha
Michelle effectivement pour peut-être
percevoir c'est quoi c'est un coup de
Jarnac un coup de poignard comment vous
interprétez-vous cette décision de du
Premier ministre britannique de voilà de
de rogner sur ses ambitions écologiques
le jour où le roi Charles fait un
discours comme celui-là il le savait de
devant les parlementaires français
justement
une partie de la presse notamment des ce
soir se demander si le passage que vous
venez de passer où il parle des
entreprises et des investissements en
lien avec la transition écologique
n'était pas peut-être une petite une
petite pique ou en tout cas une petite
référence déguisée à ce qui s'est à ce
qui s'est passé hier on cherche toujours
à lire entre les lignes des discours
royaumes et en tout cas c'est
effectivement pour projet ce que faisait
Catherine Marchal la question de la
confiance qui est qui est qui est
absolument absolument primordial ici
même si ça s'est réchauffé ces derniers
ces derniers mois cette visite c'est
vraiment le pendant soft power du sommet
franco-britannique qui a eu lieu en mars
dernier c'est le fait de reconstruire
cette confiance et effectivement le fait
de prendre des décisions un petit peu
erratiques comme ça ça peut ça peut
continuer un petit peu à brouiller les à
brouiller les les l'entente entre entre
les deux pays Catherine Morin de Saïd
quand vous entendez le discours de
Charles III notamment sur ces questions
d'économies vous dites quoi il fait de
la politique aussi ce roi il en a fait
avant tout le monde sur ce sujet en
réalité quand il y a plusieurs années
nous alerter sans sur l'environnement
danger la biodiversité remise en
question
il était visionnaire je crois que chacun
s'accorde pour le dire donc c'est
vraiment un sujet qui lui tient
particulièrement à coeur et il se fait
l'ambassadeur de cette cause à travers
le monde au-delà du discours politique
bien entendu validé par le gouvernement
britannique je voulais ajouter que lors
de cette visite nous avons l'opportunité
de rencontrer nos homologues les
parlementaires de la de la Chambre des
communes et l'ordre était présent ce qui
appartiennent au groupe d'amitié et nous
avons eu aussi des échanges en marge de
ce discours et nous avons tous manifesté
une réelle envie de travailler sur ces
sujets car la diplomatie parlementaire
joue un rôle également Sylvie Berman
vous avez côtoyé plusieurs fois
Charles quand il était encore prince
vous l'aimez même remis une décoration
c'est ça oui le commandeur de langue
nationale du mérites agricole
précisément pour ses activités depuis
des décès sur les questions de la
protection de l'environnement et il
était encore très actif puisque il avait
réuni
des enfin il est organisé une réunion
ministérielle avec elle à l'époque avait
participé Ségolène Royal sur la
protection des
océans et oui c'est un sujet qui enfin
qu'il avait à coeur depuis longtemps il
est intervenu lors de la séance
inaugurale de la COP 21 et toujours très
très convaincu et très présent sur ce
sujet Catherine est-ce que c'est un roi
qui est passé
des paroles aux actes c'est-à-dire si on
fait un peu le bilan écolo de son de sa
première année de règne alors et de son
premier à sa première année de règne il
a dû être faire extrêmement attention
puisque dans son rôle constitutionnel il
savait qu'il ne pourrait pas intervenir
autant qu'il l'avait fait en tant que
Prince de Galles donc on peut dire qu'il
a vraiment eu toute une période de sa
vie quand il était prince de Galles où
il a pu s'exprimer où il a pu avancer
sur ces questions-là en particulier la
jeunesse avec The Prince trust où il a
beaucoup fait pour c'est pour ça qu'on
fait on voit bien il a parlé du sport et
de la jeunesse et qu'il a rencontré des
jeunes je crois à Saint-Denis mais en
fait il avait aussi tout ce point de vue
holistique puisque c'est pas simplement
l'écologie c'est aussi finalement une
compréhension du monde qui est
proprement holistique par contre sa
première année on voit bien il a été
très prudent il a fait en sorte de ne
pas intervenir sur ces questions et à la
demande de rechercheuna qui n'a pas
assisté à la Coop l'année dernière
puisque et donc il a accepté il ne l'a
pas fait il a simplement reçu un
burkinium palace les membres certains et
donc on voit bien que il a bien il a
bien transformé son rôle entre prince de
Galles il a été le plus long prince de
Galles on va dire à celui de roi et là
où j'étais très intéressé dans le
discours aujourd'hui c'est que c'était
vous l'avez dit un très beau discours où
le champ lexical du du tissage et du fil
était là il a parlé de la Tapisserie de
Bayeux il a parlé de la France en tant
que Island le tissu de sa vie et il a
parlé du style d'or en tant qu'Elisabeth
et je me disais la plus belle acte de
propagande la première BD de propagande
c'est vraiment la Tapisserie de Bayeux
et je me disais on a là un vrai roi qui
en fait c'est nous charmer avec une
entreprise de propagande formidable
alors tiens le tissu de ma propre vie on
a cet extrait le roi francofiles on va
en parler évidemment ensemble écoutons
Charles III autre passage de son
discours c'était en fin de matinée ici
au Sénat devant sénateur sénatrice et
parlementaire et député réunis
les exemples de ma grand-mère et de ma
défunte mère on peut fabriquer la France
du tissu de ma propre vie
d'ailleurs j'ai été frappé
ma 35e visite officiel ici en France et
à chaque fois que je viens je suis
vraiment marqué frappée par la chaleur
de l’accueil dont je bénéficie à chaque
fois et par toutes les bonnes choses que
nous pouvons faire ensemble lorsque la
France et leur ioni travaillaient
ensemble
ma première visite d'État en France je
reste plus que jamais convaincu du
caractère indispensable de la relation
entre nos deux pays
je le disais si le Berman vous avez
souvent rencontré le prince Charles
c'est un vrai francofile c'est pas
seulement des mots un discours non c'est
un vrai francophile d'abord c'est un
homme qui est très très cultivé et qui
aime la culture française et puis c'est
l'héritage de la reine mère de la Reine
Elizabeth aussi qui malheureusement
s'arrête à sa génération puisque les
princes et le prince William n'a pas
appris le français mais oui et ce n'est
pas un hasard si il est venu très
régulièrement bon à titre officiel
remplaçant la reine mais aussi parfois à
titre privé et on sent que il y a une
véritable sincérité quand tu dis c'est
la le tissu de ma vie ça correspond à
une réalité et il connaît bien je dirais
les références du discours et c'est
c'est pas fin de même que la qualité de
son français son français parce que bien
sûr
c'est un discours qui est rédigé mais
qui lit parfaitement bien sans buter sur
les mots comme quelqu'un qui ne
connaîtrait pas vraiment la langue donc
c'est pas un chanteur qui est une
chanteuse qui qui enregistre un titre en
japonais sans sans comprendre le sens
des mots évidemment je sais pas pourquoi
cette analogie évolue des fois et des
trucs comme ça
[Rires]
il y a eu dans revenons aux choses
sérieuses dans le discours de de Charles
III sur cette question euh
de la francophilie moi il y a un passage
qui m'a étonné quand il dit mettons en
commun les forces de du commonwealt et
pays du Common et des pays de la
francophonie comment comment vous
réagissez à ça qu'est-ce que j'étais
très sensible à cette approche
d'ailleurs qui a été évoqué par le
président de l'argent et également donc
il y a cette volonté dans la
mondialisation de de rapprochement de
ces grandes communautés alors qui ont
des vraies différences mais qui peuvent
avoir en commun la défense de la
diversité culturelle la défense des
droits de l'homme et un certain nombre
de sujets dont la préoccupation du
développement durable et soutenable de
de la planète et je crois qu'on a besoin
d'instance de ce type aussi dans les
temps que nous traversons dans un monde
fait de menaces il a évoqué aussi la
guerre revenu sur le sol européen avec
les signifie il a
parlé de défi à plusieurs reprises je
crois que ces instances aussi nous
réfléchissons la francophonie ça tombe
de pays le comme l'Ouest également et
ils sont issus de tous les continents du
monde c'est la particularité des deux
instances tous les candidats ils se
représentaient c'est important mais
alors quand j'entends ça Catherine
Marchal ma première réaction mais je
j'avoue voilà peut-être que c'est un peu
sinig de ma part je me dis mais ça va
déboucher sur quoi
le roi dit ça très bien mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe après ça peut prendre
quelle forme alors moi je pense ça peut
prendre une très belle forme en effet
parce que c'est un projet commun dans
lesquels vous pouvez avoir vous pouvez
rassembler à la fin vous pouvez aussi
rassembler des étudiants vous pouvez
rassembler en fait des communautés qui
vont se comprendre sur un sujet qui est
commun et qui les touche puisqu'on voit
bien qu'en fait les pays touchés par les
problèmes de développement durable sont
en effet une grande partie des pays du
commonwear c'est une grande partie des
pays la francophonie donc peut-être
qu'en effet il y a quelque chose à faire
là alors oui peut-être quand il dit ça
pardon nous interrompre il sait puisque
effectivement c'était une partie du Tour
de gérarchique
c'est déjà dans les tuyaux pardon d'être
un peu trivial alors là dessus je ne
sais pas je pense qu'en effet je pense
que madame la sénatrice le saura
peut-être mieux que moi mais je pense
que pour le coup moi je j'écoute ça en
me disant je vois ce qui peut être fait
derrière je vois pas en fait un aspect
politique alors oui il vient en effet
donner un discours dans lequel il faut
impulser quelque chose mais finalement
est-ce que cette impulsion là elle est
pas peut-être plus intéressante que
d'autres il y a des exemples peut-être
de d'impulsion comme ça de de projet
lancé par alors peut-être la reine
auparavant ou vous voyez qui ont été
suivies de de réalité il y a déjà des
contacts entre le Common c'est le hello
if il est le à la tête du Commonwealth
il a placé la la reine dans ses
fonctions mais à la suite enfin même
dans le contexte de la campagne du
brexit l'idée c'est que le commonway ça
les remplacer l'Union bon ce qui était
une illusion totale donc c'était une
version un petit peu agressive de ce que
devait être le Commonwealth et
aujourd'hui au contraire il appelle à la
coopération mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
déjà eu entre les secrétaires généraux
des deux organisations des relations et
puis après effectivement ça peut être
décliné à un autre niveau pour des
étudiants et des chercheurs on va se
poser une question toute simple
maintenant et je propose Alexandre
Poussard de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau mais pourquoi le roi Charles III
a-t-il choisi le Sénat bienvenue on est
heureux de vous accueillir de nouveau
Alexandre
pourquoi le Sénat et bien d'abord Thomas
pour s'inscrire dans les pas de sa mère
Elisabeth II la reine était venue au
Sénat en 2004 pour fêter le centenaire
de l'entente cordiale et sa visite avait
suivi un peu le même programme de celle
de que celle de Charles III elle avait
été reçue par les sénateurs et les
députés réunis au Palais du Luxembourg
elle avait à l'époque également obtenu
un discours devant les parlementaires
mais ce n'était pas dans l'hémicycle
c'était en salle des conférences on va
l'écouter notre attachement mutuelle à
la démocratie parlementaire et le socle
de notre liberté et de nos valeurs
communes
continuent de jouer un rôle immense
non seulement à l'échelle nationale mais
aussi dans l'édification de l'Europe de
demain et puis c'est aussi Alexandre une
visite qui permet de rendre hommage à la
démocratie parlementaire oui on le
rappelle le Royaume-Uni et la plus
ancienne démocratie parlementaire il y a
une forme d'admiration des Français pour
cela et ce choix du Sénat c'était aussi
un hommage au bicamerisme un parlement à
deux chambres nos deux démocraties sont
organisées selon ce système en France
l'Assemblée nationale et Sénat au
Royaume-Uni la Chambre des communes et
la Chambre des lords et puis pour Gérard
Larcher le président de la Haute
Assemblée et bien ce choix il met en
valeur les collectivités territoriales
qui sont représentées par le Sénat on va
l'écouter vous avez choisi sûr comme la
reine Elizabeth II lors de sa visite
d'État en 2004 de vous rendre au Sénat
nous voulons y percevoir un hommage au
territoire de la République
que les souverains britanniques ont
aussi assis du Mans parcourus et que le
Sénat représente les collectivités
territoriales
de au travers notamment des communes
on nous est temps de relations entre
elles
elles sont le socle le plus solide de
notre amitié alors on peut noter aussi
que le Sénat est un précurseur en terme
de diplomatie parlementaire puisque il y
a 30 ans le Sénat avait reçu pour la
première fois un chef d'État étranger
dans l'enceinte du Parlement français
c'était le chancelier allemand elmodcall
et puis dernière raison qui pourrait
expliquer ce choix du Sénat pour cette
visite royale et bien c'était au sein du
Palais du Luxembourg un ancien palais
royal qui avait été construit pour la
reine Marie de Médicis et puis tant pis
si ce palais a aussi été le lieu de du
pouvoir de Napoléon qui n'était pas un
grand ami des Britanniques on peut dire
ça comme ça merci beaucoup alexandres
vers vous parce que quand on voit et
c'est son destin depuis un an quand on
voit Charles on pense à sa mère
forcément il y a ce comparatif en terme
de charisme est-ce que vous vous l'avez
ressenti aussi voilà écoutez son
discours à scruter des gestes moi je lui
trouve du rayonnement et une forme de
charisme je crois que il faut pas
comparer les personnes c'est vrai que
Isabelle 2 de part aussi la longévité de
son règne avait ce charisme incroyable
on voit les réactions au lendemain de
son décès mais je pense que
cet engagement justement du prince de
Galles que vous avez bien rappelé
Catherine autour d'une cause qui est si
importante aujourd'hui lui confère
beaucoup d'humanité et de et de
crédibilité je trouve aussi dans dans
son engagement même s'il y a encore une
fois c'est un engagement qui est un
engagement de la diplomatie mais pas un
engagement politique de part la façon
dont tout ça est construit en
Grande-Bretagne cette intervention de
Elisabeth II à l'intérieur dans un
contexte politique particulier on est
pas longtemps après le refus de la
France de participer à la guerre on ira
que le discours de Dominique de Villepin
et on entend que voilà à l'effet
allusion Elizabeth II on n'a pas pu tout
mettre est-ce que quand même
Elisabeth II dont on a beaucoup dit
qu'elle était pas politique et que
peut-être Charles le serait un peu plus
et elle n'était pas quand même un peu
politique parfois avec des petits
signaux et même plus que ça là dans ce
genre de discours oui tout à fait en
tout cas elle a toujours joué un rôle
diplomatique parce que une visite de des
abeilles de comme d'ailleurs le roi
Charles ça a le même sens c'est un
signal de réchauffement de rapprochement
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que richissouna
qui trouvait aussi un intérêt au départ
d'ailleurs c'était une séquence très
très rapprochée donc oui les souverains
britanniques jouent un rôle diplomatique
et pas politique Sacha Michelle je
reviens vers vous si on fait un peu le
bilan de cette première année de règne
de du roi Charles III il y avait il y
avait des craintes en Angleterre d'un
affaiblissement de la monarchie après le
le décès d'Elisabeth II il y avait des
craintes à ce sujet un petit peu
effectivement dans la presse plus ou qui
le disait plus ou moins plus ou moins
ouvertement et puis au bout d'un an et
force c'est de constater que tout le
monde est un petit peu bluffé tout se
passe dans la continuité il y a une
période de deuil à une période de
transition mais tout tout se passe dans
la continuité il y a pas eu de gaffe
notable c'est ce qu'on craignait un
petit peu il y a pas eu
d'affaiblissement non plus marqué dieu
de la popularité de la monarchie dans
l'opinion publique à part chez les
jeunes et c'est une question qui va
devoir à mon avis
occupé pas mal d'esprits à Buckingham
Palace parce que c'est l'image future de
la monarchie qui est qui est en jeu là
et puis pour revenir sur ce que vous
disiez un petit peu avant sur le
commonwald et la francophonie
la presse à noter que au concept
première année donc il y a eu un
réchauffement des une relation avec avec
les voisins européens il y a eu pas mal
de choses faites aussi sur
l'environnement et il manquait un petit
peu le commonwealt Charles 3 doit se
rendre au Kenya bientôt et là aussi ça
va être un défi assez important parce
que il est à la tête du commonwald
remplacement de de la reine Élisabeth II
mais c'était pas automatique c'est un
une il est à la tête parce qu'on la
reine a proposé qu'il soit à la tête le
monarque britannique n'est pas forcément
à la tête du corps malade et puis au
sein des pays du commonwalt il y en a
certains qui sont à ne plus avoir
Charles III comme ou en tout cas le roi
d'Angleterre comme comme chef d'État je
pense notamment à la Jamaïque pourraient
suivre l'exemple de la Barbade il y a
deux ans presque maintenant donc voilà
les défis sont devant la première année
c'est plutôt bien passée mais les défis
sont devant Catherine je vais être un
peu trial on a mis les sujets qui
fâchent sous le tapis pendant cette
première année oui en fait je pense que
votre
la personne ici pardonnez-moi elle vient
juste de le dire je pense que en effet
il y a eu des sujets qui ont quand même
été un petit peu compliqué on n'a pas
peut-être pas non plus évoqué les
problèmes à l'intérieur de même de la
famille royale puisqu'en fait vous avez
des problèmes de la jeunesse vous avez
les problèmes de la famille royale avec
le prince Harry et vous avez aussi les
problèmes du commonwears alors on vient
de dévoquer en effet il y a la question
des pays qui voudraient peut-être
devenir des républiques dans les 14
royaumes du commonwei mais vous avez en
fait peut-être aussi une question
derrière qui sera celle des réparations
et en fait ce sont des sujets qui vont
revenir il y a aussi un peut-être un
dernier sujet qui qui pointe et qui est
revenu plusieurs fois c'est la question
de de la fortune qui que la monarchie à
travers ce qu'on appelle le duché de
Lancaster donc en fait ce sont des
questions qui pour l'instant ont été
mises de côté je pense aussi que le roi
Charles III a eu beaucoup de chance
aussi d'arriver à une période où
finalement il a eu comme première
ministre quelqu'un comme les strass qui
rappelons-le et restait à peine 50 jours
et qui finalement n'a ne laissera pas
une grande trace donc du coup il est un
peu comme une fille bizarrement comme
une feature de stabilité qui arrivait
finalement pour un peu comme l'adulte au
milieu des enfants c'est un peu et parce
que c'est vrai qu'on est fait son âge
aussi je joue pour lui et confond on se
dit bon oui il a été prince de Galles
mais finalement mieux ses premières
rencontres importantes
Emmanuel Lacron l'a rappelé hier soir
c'était aux objets obsèques de Charles
de Gaulle mais vous avez aussi les
rencontres avec Nexon dans les années 70
c'est quelqu'un qui a une expérience
absolument incroyable et qui comparait à
des hommes politiques comme comme les
strass sont beaucoup plus importants et
c'est fort mais ça c'est on l'a beaucoup
dit pour pour la reine Elizabeth ça
Sylvie Bernadet c'est enfin c'est une
évidence je veux dire mais le privilège
d'un roi ou d'une reine c'est le temps
et il voit défiler des premiers
ministres dans son bureau quoi oui mais
bien sûr la reine Elizabeth c'était
l'histoire avec un grand âge parce
qu'elle a rencontré tous les grandes de
ce monde pendant des décennies mais
c'est vrai que l'interrogation qu'il
pouvait savoir sur les capacités du
prince Charles à être roi était tout à
fait surprenante parce que il avait une
expérience diplomatique sans pareil vous
avez rappelé effectivement toutes les
rencontres qu'il a eu depuis longtemps
c'est lui qui se rendait aux réunion du
commonwei c'est je pense que personne au
Royaume-Uni n'a une telle expertise
diplomatique quand la reine est décédée
il y avait effectivement un certain
nombre d'interrogations alors sur ces
compétences j'en sais rien sur sa
popularité également parce que il y
avait toujours en arrière fonce cette
histoire de Diana mais aussi parce que
on lui avait reproché d'être trop
intrusifs sur les questions de
gouvernement puisqu'il écrivait des
lettres à tous les membres du groupe
comme ça parce que d'abord il a eu une
encre noire et puis un peu des pattes de
mouche quand il écrivait et pendant des
années c'est le gardien qui avait
demandé la publication de ses lettres le
procureur général avait refusé et
absolument et c'est vrai qu'il est
bombardait un petit peu de lettres et
finalement quand ça a été publié
l'affaire s'est arrêtée parce que
c'était sur les questions d'écologie sur
les questions du bien-être des soldats
donc uniquement sur sur des thèmes qui
étaient tout à fait honorables et donc
il y avait cette crainte qui soit aussi
interventionniste mais évidemment
d'ailleurs il l'a dit un jour il sait
très bien quels sont les fonctions
constitutionnelles d'un pays sans
constitution d'ailleurs et donc il joue
parfaitement le rôle aujourd'hui savait
surpris certains journaux moi j'ai été
beaucoup à Londres pendant cette cette
période là et ils ont été agréablement
surpris
[Musique]
depuis que nous ne sommes pas tous côte
à côte pour la libération de l'Europe
nous faisons face encore une fois à
agression injustifiée sur notre
continent
notre détermination et notre alliance
sont plus importantes
importantes que jamais
on semble nous nous tenons au foot de
peuple ukrainien avec une solidarité
ensemble nous sommes inébranlables dans
notre détermination que l'Ukraine Trion
fera et que nos libertés si chers
là aussi Catherine Morin de saillie
c'est enfin il avait sans doute prévu de
dire ça mais ça intervient alors qu'on
apprend que la Pologne a décidé
d'arrêter de livrer des armes à
l'Ukraine sur fond de contentieux sur
les exportations
ukrainiennes de blé enfin c'est
un c'est un une déclaration qui prend
encore plus de force est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça tout à fait elle
est très ferme très précise très résolue
et je crois que ça fait du bien aussi
d'entendre ce discours moi ça m'a
particulièrement ému parce que il a bien
rappelé que depuis 80 ans voilà il n'y
avait pas eu la guerre en Europe nous
allons célébrer d'ici quelques mois en
Normandie dans ma région de 80ème
anniversaire du deck et on connaît le
prix de liberté on connaît le prix de la
paix et qu'il cite ses événements et
tout à fait crucial je crois à l'instant
où nous où nous parlons merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce des
bacettaires passionnants j'ai rappelé
Sylvie Berman les titres de vos livres
celui qui est concerné qui concerne le
l'Angleterre et le Royaume-Uni goodbye
butaniel le Royaume-Uni face au défi du
brexit et puis votre tout dernier alors
c'est chez Stock et le tout dernier chez
Talandier madame l'ambassadeur merci
encore d'avoir participé à ce débat on
se dit à dimanche et on donne
rendez-vous à au téléspectateurs de
Public Sénat pour une journée spéciale
élection sénatoriales ça commence dès
12h30 avec Alexandre poussat aux
manettes et puis tous les résultats à
partir de 17h30 jusqu'à
22h30 toute la rédaction toutes les
équipes de Public Sénat sont évidemment
mobilisées pour vous faire vivre ce
moment important de notre vie politique
et puis notez que demain dans la
matinale mon signe reçoit monseigne ur
Mathieu rouget l'évêque de Nanterre à
quelques heures de l'arrivée du pape à
Marseille belle soirée à toutes et à
tous à dimanche
[Musique]